que uno de los sitios que gestionaba,
una página de extrema derecha, debía bloquearse.
Luego envió un correo electrónico interno a sus compañeros de trabajo.
"Esta fue una decisión arbitraria.
Me desperté esa mañana de mal humor
y decidí echarlos de internet".
Incluso él admite,
"Nadie debería tener este poder".
Como respuesta uno de los empleados le preguntó:
"¿Es este el día en que muere internet?"
No creo que estemos matando internet,
pero sí creo que estamos en medio
de una especie de proceso de centralización irresponsable.
Eso hace que nuestra internet sea más frágil.
La web descentralizada, de persona a persona
resuelve este problema eliminando los puntos centrales,
los servicios de alojamiento web.
Esto faculta a los usuarios
tener sitios de alojamiento que quieran conservar.
En esta red los sitios se descargan directamente de otros visitantes.
Esto significa que, si uno tiene un sitio con 100 visitantes,
está alojado por 100 computadoras en todo el mundo.
Básicamente, esta es una versión de internet impulsada por las personas.
La seguridad de la red la proporciona la criptografía de clave pública.
Esto asegura que nadie pueda modificar los sitios,
solo el verdadero dueño.
Piensen en ello como, en vez de obtener electricidad
de grandes centrales eléctricas,
ponen Uds. paneles solares encima de su casa.
Y si su vecino de la calle necesita un poco de energía adicional,
simplemente puede descargar algo de su casa.
Así que mediante el uso de la web descentralizada,
podemos ayudar a mantener el contenido accesible a otros visitantes.
Y eso significa
que también podemos luchar contra las cosas
que pensamos que son injustas,
como la censura.
En China la internet está muy controlada.
No se puede criticar al gobierno,
organizar una protesta,
y está prohibido publicar
un emoticono para recordar a las víctimas de la Masacre de la Plaza de Tiananmen.
Con la web descentralizada, no es el gobierno quien decide
qué se ve y qué no.
Son las personas
quienes hace que la web sea más democrática.
Pero al mismo tiempo, es difícil usar esta red,
hacer algo que es claramente ilegal
en todas las partes del mundo,
ya que los usuarios probablemente no quieren ponerse en peligro
alojando este tipo de contenido problemático.
Otra amenaza creciente
a la libertad de internet
es el exceso de regulación.
Tengo la impresión
de que nuestros delegados
que votan las leyes que regulan internet,
no son plenamente conscientes de sus decisiones.
Por ejemplo, el Parlamento Europeo tiene una nueva ley sobre la mesa,
una nueva ley de protección de derechos de autor,
que incluye el artículo 13.
Si se aprueba, implicaría que cada gran sitio web
implemente un filtro
que bloquee automáticamente el contenido
basado en reglas controladas por grandes corporaciones.
La idea original es proteger los materiales con derechos de autor,
Pero pondría en peligro muchas otras cosas que hacemos en internet:
bloguear, criticar, discutir, enlazar y compartir.
Google y YouTube ya tienen sistemas similares
y están recibiendo 100 000 solicitudes de eliminación cada hora.
Por supuesto, no pueden procesar esta cantidad de datos a mano,
por eso utilizan el aprendizaje automático
para decidir si es realmente una violación de derechos de autor o no.
Pero estos filtros cometen errores.
Eliminan todo de la documentación de abusos a los derechos humanos,
conferencias sobre derechos de autor
y resultados de búsqueda.
Eso apunta a la crítica de este nuevo artículo 13.
Además de eso, también están eliminando muchas otras cosas.
Y a veces, estos filtros no solo eliminan el contenido específico,
sino también podría llevar a la pérdida de sus cuentas vinculadas:
dirección de correo electrónico, documentos, fotos
o su libro sin terminar,
lo que ya le sucedió al escritor Dennis Cooper.
No es difícil ver cómo se puede abusar de un sistema como este
en manos de políticos y competidores corporativos.
Ese artículo 13, la extensión de los filtros automatizados a todo internet,
tiene fuerte oposición
de Wikipedia, Github, Mozilla y muchos otros,
incluidos los fundadores originales de internet y la World Wide Web,
Vint Cerf y Tim Berners-Lee.
Pero a pesar de esta fuerte oposición,
en la última votación del Parlamento Europeo,
dos tercios de los representantes apoyaron esta ley.
La votación final será a principios de 2019.
El resultado es importante,
pero pase lo que pase,
estoy bastante seguro de que será seguido por muchas otras propuestas similares
en todo el mundo.
Este tipo de regulaciones serían muy difíciles de hacer cumplir
a través de una web descentralizada,
Como no habría empresas de alojamiento,
los sitios web serían atendidos por los propios visitantes.
Comencé a construir esta red hace tres años.
Desde entonces, he pasado miles, decenas de miles de horas
desarrollándola.
¿Por qué?
¿Por qué alguien gastaría tanto tiempo en algo que cualquiera pueda libremente
copiar, renombrar o incluso vender?
Bueno, en mi caso,
una de las razones era hacer algo significativo.
Durante mi trabajo diario como desarrollador web,
no tuve la sensación de estar trabajando en algo
que me diera la oportunidad de ser más grande que yo.
Simplemente, solo quería tener mi corta presencia en este mundo
siendo significativo.
El año pasado, el Gran Cortafuegos chino comenzó a bloquear esta red que creé.
Este movimiento me hizo oficialmente enemigo
de la censura de internet apoyada por el gobierno.
Desde entonces, ha sido realmente un juego de gato y ratón.
Desarrollan nuevas reglas en el cotafuegos
y trato de reaccionar lo antes posible
para que los usuarios puedan seguir alojando contenido y creando sitios web
que de lo contrario sería censurados por la internet centralizada china.
Mi otra motivación para crear esta red fue la preocupación.
Me temo que el futuro de nuestra internet está fuera de nuestro control.
La creciente centralización y las leyes propuestas
amenazan nuestra libertad de expresión
y con ello nuestra democracia.
Así que para mí, construir una web descentralizada.
significa crear un puerto seguro,
un espacio donde las reglas no las escriban
grandes corporaciones y partidos políticos, sino las personas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)